this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skill share learned to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking on a link in the description
unidentified federal officers wearing
full camouflage jumping out of unmarked
vehicles picking up seemingly random
protesters handcuffing them and then
speeding away this isn't George Orwell's
1984 this is America 2020 Portland
Oregon there have been over 50 straight
days of protests in Portland Oregon
sparked by the murders of George Floyd
and Brianna Taylor and other citizens
killed by police these protests have
been mostly peaceful but a few people
have committed acts of vandalism and
property damage but back in June
president Trump activated at least a
dozen different law enforcement agencies
to quote restore order during protests
in Washington DC thousands and thousands
of heavily armed soldiers at the time
the federal government justified this
show of force with vague references to
DC status says not a state but the show
of force actually had little to do with
DC's precarious legal status instead the
response in DC was more like a dry run a
first attempt at using federal police to
stop protests now more than a hundred
law enforcement officers have been
deployed to Portland Oregon and many of
those officers are not identifying
themselves verbally or through insignia
on their uniforms they're driving around
in vehicles not marked as law
enforcement and they refuse to say who
they are even to those that they arrest
they have apparently kidnapped
protesters off the street and taken them
to jail cells they've gone on the
offensive and they've shot protesters
with kinetic impact munitions federal
officers have also sprayed tear gas at
protesters prompting organ Long's to
form a human shield to protect people
who were peacefully protesting they've
attacked a Navy veteran who came to ask
officers whether they understood the
oath that they took to the US
Constitution who just didn't respond
like an absolute boss all of this
happened without the approval of Oregon
State officials all in all this is a
chilling show of force in allegedly free
society are we witnessing military
detention of protesters does the federal
government have authority to do this and
do protesters have the right to fight
back and stand their ground against
people who are not clearly identified as
law enforcement and most importantly how
worried should we all be
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because there are reports of
protesters in Portland Oregon being
disappeared by federal law enforcement
potentially operating outside of its
jurisdictional limits now in this
episode we're going to explain what the
heck is going on in Portland and if
you're upset about what's happening
you're not alone in fact Oregon has
already filed suit against the federal
government to stop these tactics but
let's begin at the beginning with the
jurisdiction of federal law enforcement
officers operating in the States the
basic questions are which law
enforcement agencies have authority over
federal land in property and under what
circumstances can federal law
enforcement go beyond just federal land
and operate within the jurisdiction of
the state now Congress has the authority
to create law enforcement organizations
to patrol and protect areas of federal
property violations occurring within the
federal land will then be handled by
federal law enforcement officers for
example the Bureau of Land Management
has the authority to undertake
traditional police activities on beelin
the the other BLM lands which include
national parks but they cannot make
arrests under state laws unless they
have written authorization by state or
local officials according to an opinion
by the Office of Legal Counsel in 2012
federal law enforcement personnel lacked
the authority to make arrests under
state law and remember state law is
generally the one that we think of when
we think of general criminal activities
the stuff that police often arrest
people under unless that Authority is
expressly granted by either federal or
state law and the federal officers
exercise of authority complies with the
purpose Act which requires that federal
funds be used only for the purposes for
which they were appropriated by the way
I am deeply indebted to law professor
and law fair contributor Steve lattic on
this he's on twitter @steveadubato
so which law enforcement agencies are
active in situations like this well the
law enforcement response in Washington
DC involved many different agencies and
the National Guard and by most accounts
the DC response was coordinated by
attorney general bar bar has legal
authority to coordinate law enforcement
officers who are under the jurisdiction
of the Department of Justice like the
FBI in the Federal Bureau of Prisons
in contrast the federal officers who are
in Portland appeared to be from the
Customs and Border Protection CBP is
under the jurisdiction of the Department
of Homeland Security so let's talk about
the CBP's Authority in Portland
does it have legal authority to operate
in Portland well yes it probably does
the Fourth Amendment of the Constitution
protects Americans from random and
arbitrary stops and searches however
these basic constitutional principles do
not apply fully at the borders at border
crossings including the ports of entry
by the sea federal authorities do not
need a warrant or even suspicion of
wrongdoing to justify conducting what
the courts have called a quote routine
search such as searching luggage or a
vehicle the federal officers cannot
suspend the US Constitution but the
Supreme Court has given them more leeway
in these activities federal regulations
approved by the Supreme Court give the
CBP authority to operate within 100
miles of any US quote external boundary
the closest international border to
Portland is the Pacific Ocean and the
ocean is less than a hundred miles away
from Portland which gives the CBP
specific enforcement powers this
relaxation of constitutional protections
within a hundred miles of any external
border and or an ocean has received a
lot of criticism from civil libertarians
which correctly point out that the vast
majority of Americans live within a
hundred miles of an external border
although CBP has legal authority to
enforce federal laws in Portland they
cannot enforce state laws for example
CBP must have reasonable suspicion of an
immigration violation or violation of
federal law in order to pull someone
over and to stop them but of course not
surprisingly the federal government does
have authority to protect federal
property and to investigate offenses
against that federal property in federal
land and generally the federal agency
that's tasked with protecting federal
property is the Federal Protective
Service not the CBP but here and perhaps
in the future Customs and Border
Patrol's being authorized under 40 USC
1315 which allows the Department of
Homeland Security Secretary to designate
other DHS officers to backstop the
Federal Protective Service section 1315
which was enacted over a decade ago
empowers the Department of Homeland
Security to quote make arrests with
warrant for any offense against the
United States committed in the presence
of the officer or agent or for any
felony cognizable under the laws of the
United States if the officer or agent
has reasonable grounds to believe that
the person to be arrested has committed
or is committing a felony and under the
section unless the federal officer
personally witnesses a federal crime
being committed or has a reason to
believe an individual committed a
federal offense the only authority under
section 1315 is to investigate offenses
against federal property which again is
generally the purview of the Federal
Protective Services and really here the
$64,000 question is what qualifies as an
investigation of an offense against
federal property but regardless of the
authorization of these regulations
they're still limited by the
Constitution in order to be able to
physically stop someone you need
reasonable suspicion and according to
the Supreme Court in order to put
someone in a van and drive them away you
have to have probable cause and here
there are reports admittedly one-sided
reports coming from the protesters
themselves that it doesn't seem like the
federal officers have those kind of
justifications and it also appears that
the federal officers are operating
pretty far away from the federal
property that they've been tasked to
protect and potentially to investigate
crimes related to well we're 49 straight
days into violence and destruction in
Portland
so it justifies the response because
violence and destruction continue and
that's not to say that the protests in
Portland have been entirely nonviolent
it can be the case as it appears to be
here that there can be some people who
are out riding and committing acts of
violence and vandalism well the vast
majority of people are peacefully
protesting and the thing about that is
that even if simple acts of vandalism
did justify the use of force and query
whether that's true or not that doesn't
justify using force against the
overwhelmingly peaceful protesters of
Portland and lots of other American
cities
this is a posture we intend to continue
not just in Portland but in any of the
facilities that were responsible for
around the country America is not under
siege by protesters and there's a
concept in the First Amendment called
the hecklers veto
that you are not allowed to use the
violent reaction of a minority to quell
the speech activity of the majority
that's a hecklers veto and we don't want
that but you don't have to take my word
for it let's kick it over to our
correspondent in the field Portland
resident and mom in the mom wall and my
sister little Eagle Eagle
legal eagle we are here on a weekday
it's about 9:45 p.m. and as you can hear
we're singing dorky songs and the moms
and dads are out in the thousands it
feels very safe actually right now so
even though everybody has come prepared
with teargas accoutrements some goggles
some some helmets a lot people are
passing out water so far it has felt
very peaceful and everybody is singing
and getting along very well so it's it's
been a really wonderful experience so
far crowd has so far been very peaceful
so how this all started it is a protest
for black lives matter of course spun
off by the murder of George Floyd and
since then here in the past three nights
there have been thousands of mom that
have shown up to create a wall of moms
so the idea here is that all of us are
in yellow the dads are out tonight as
well in orange and we that the theme is
that we're protecting the youth that are
indiscriminately in ilegally being
abducted beaten any number of things by
the feds that have come into our city so
so far the night has been absolutely
lovely it's a warm balmy evening we
people have been passing out these
little pig squeakers which has been kind
of delightful very Portland of the city
and otherwise we've been singing there
have been people of color representing
and speaking up on stage and a lot of
chants so it's been a really nice night
thanks little sis really truly
terrifying stuff I haven't seen that
kind of carnage since the women's March
of aught 17 stay safe out there and
don't get a paper cut on all those signs
so the next question naturally is what
federal laws are CBP officers trying to
enforce in Portland unlike Washington DC
where there's quite a lot of federal
property
Oregon really doesn't have that much
property that's under the exclusive
jurisdiction of the federal
government federal law enforcement
officers can arrest someone who
vandalizes a federal building like a
courthouse which there are some in
downtown Portland and federal
immigration authorities can't arrest
people for suspicion of violating
immigration laws and for violating any
federal law provided the federal offense
happened in the officers presence but
federal law enforcement officers don't
have the authority to enforce state laws
on non-federal property and when you're
talking about vandalism of non federal
property that would clearly be as
state-based law and here the governor of
Oregon does not want federal law
enforcement in her state that leaves us
with a complicated situation that's
susceptible to abuse by overzealous
federal officers so are federal officers
simply protecting federal courthouses
from vandalism in Portland it definitely
doesn't look that way report suggests
that cbv officers are roaming the
streets a considerable distance from
federal property
for example protester mark Pettibone was
suddenly seized by camo clad people and
thrown into an unmarked minivan
Pettibone was taken to a cell in a
federal courthouse where he was asked if
he would waive his rights he answered no
and was then apparently released
Pettibone wasn't charged with a crime he
says that the men who grabbed him did
not identify themselves
CBP said that Pettibone and others who
were detained were wanted for
destruction of federal property or
assault on federal officers but there's
been no proof of these allegations yet
though and the fact that these people
are being detained thrown in a Cell and
then released without charges makes
these arrests seem pretty dubious CVB
denies that its officers are not
identified the agency told reporters
that their uniforms have a CBB patch but
officers are not identified by name
because they might be ducks which might
put their lives in danger this might
strike some view as an acceptable reason
not to identify officers by name but
note that even Army soldiers in Iraq and
Afghanistan wear names on their uniforms
both in English and Arabic is the
average Portland protester a greater
Menace than Isis or al-qaeda and by the
way if you want a great breakdown
between the differences between police
tactics and army tactics check out my
friend knowing betters channel where he
talks about his experience serving in
the military in Afghanistan and the
differences between military and police
and the overlap between the two as well
legal commentator Ken wide probably put
it best federalism except for occupying
cities and beating and detaining people
on suspicion of
and ilysm so now we get to the heart of
the matter did federal Leo's violate the
law well let's talk about the lack of
identification why is it bad for law
enforcement to go around without
identification well first and foremost a
person or suspect might refused to
respond to an order from a law
enforcement official who doesn't clearly
identify themselves there's also the
danger that various law enforcement
officers might not be able to recognize
each other especially since many
different military and police groups are
involved in both both DC and Portland
and riot helmets often have identifying
numbers on their backs partly for this
reason but the big reason obviously is
that if officers don't identify
themselves then they can't be held
accountable for their misbehavior
this is especially egregious because the
protests are directly calling for police
accountability and amenity it might be a
good thing in war but it's very bad when
the officers are controlling
demonstrations in their own country and
the precise legal question of whether
it's reasonable for an officer to refuse
to identify him or herself by name and
state who he works for has not really
been decided by federal courts obviously
when officers are undercover it would be
reasonable for them to remain anonymous
but in situations like a protest it's
vitally important for people to know
that they're being stopped by police
instead of by civilians and courts have
generally held that officers should
identify themselves in these situations
but it's still a novel legal issue at
least from a federal standpoint there's
no federal law that requires federal law
enforcement officers to wear a name tag
to wear a specific identifiable number
that can be attributed to the individual
officer in part probably because federal
law enforcement has been very very
curtailed and where it can be used in
the US and its really very recently that
they are expanding outside of their
clear mandate but just because there's
no federal law that applies here doesn't
mean that state law doesn't control and
while there is no federal law requiring
federal officers to wear insignia
identifying themselves or individual
nametags Oregon law does require any law
enforcement officers purporting to
enforce state law to conspicuously
display an official identification card
showing the officers lawful authority
Oregon authorizes federal officers to
enforce state law but only under
specific circumstances a federal officer
may arrest someone
for a crime committed in the officers
presence if the person has probable
cause under Oregon's authorization of
federal law enforcement officers a
federal officer may arrest someone for a
crime committed in the officers presence
if the person has probable cause the
officer informs the person to be
arrested of the officers authority and
reason for the arrest and the officer
takes the arrested person to a peace
officer or magistrate without delay and
there's one other legal requirement the
federal officer cannot make arrest for
state criminal violations unless they
receive Oregon training and are
certified by the state this tells us
some important things first a federal
CBP officer could arrest someone for a
violation of Oregon state law but only
if they have probable cause second the
arrest is only legal if the officer
tells the person the basis for their
authority who they are and who they work
for and third the federal officer must
swiftly bring that person before a judge
or magistrate so they're notified about
their charges and rights and fourth the
federal officer must be certified by the
state of Oregon to make arrests pursuant
to law which takes us to the first of
many lawsuits here based on what we know
it doesn't seem like the federal
officers in Portland can prove that they
meet one or any of these conditions
Oregon governor Kate brown in Portland
Mayor Ted wheeler have implored DHS to
remove CBP and other federal officers
from the state the Oregon Department of
Justice has filed a lawsuit accusing DHS
and other agencies of unlawful law
enforcement in addition to CBP the state
has identified other active law
enforcement agencies as the US Marshal
Service and the Federal Protective
Service the failure of federal officers
to identify themselves is actually one
of the reasons for this lawsuit the
complaint names 10 John Doe defendants
who are just placeholders that you put
in a lawsuit complaint until you know
the actual identity of that person and
names the tendo defendants who quote
have made it impossible for them to be
individually identified by carrying out
law enforcement actions without wearing
any identifying information even so much
as the agency that employs them the
lawsuit seeks a temporary restraining
order to prevent federal authorities
from unlawfully detain or agon residents
like mark Pettibone according to the
suit Oregonians have the right to walk
through downtown Portland at night and
in the early hours of the morning
ordinarily a person exercising his right
to walk through the streets of Portland
who is
confronted by anonymous men in military
type fatigues and ordered into an
unmarked van can reasonably assumed that
he's being kidnapped and is the victim
of a crime
this suit alleges that this is an
unreasonable search and seizure in
violation of the Fourth Amendment which
will be repeated if the federal
government is not enjoined from its
activities the complaint alleges that
this activity of federal law enforcement
officers violate Oregon citizens First
Amendment right to protest since quote
citizens who are reasonably afraid of
being picked up and shoved into unmarked
vans possibly by federal officers
possibly by individuals opposed to
protests will feel compelled to stay
away for their own personal safety and
will therefore be unable to express
themselves in the way that they have a
right to do the State Attorney General
alleges that the federal government did
not notify or coordinate with state
officers essentially the state is saying
that the federal government just showed
up to the protest without any requests
from state or local authorities or
training by the state the ACLU of Oregon
has also filed a lawsuit against the
Department of Homeland Security and the
US Marshal Service
the ACLU cz's lawsuit seeks to block
federal law enforcement from dispersing
arresting threatening to arrest or using
physical force against journalists or
legal observers the plaintiffs in that
case include the newspaper of the
Portland mercury and individual
journalists and legal observers who say
that they were attacked by federal law
enforcement the ACLU is planning several
lawsuits on behalf of protesters who say
that their rights were violated so this
may be the tip of the iceberg so is this
a constitutional crisis of the federal
government against the states well
Governor Brown has told federal officers
to get out and President Trump said no
the federal government has officially
refused the state's request to withdraw
a federal law enforcement from the state
the state can argue that it has certain
powers reserved to it by the Tenth
Amendment and while there's a real
difficulty balancing governmental
response to domestic crises the states
generally have flexibility and authority
to respond as they see the needs of
their citizens and at the same time the
federal government also has a right to
respond to federal crises the video that
I did a few weeks back on Posse
Comitatus and the insurrection act laid
out some of these issues the founders
were afraid of concentrating too much
power in the presidency or the federal
government and one of the checks on the
tyrannical government was to give States
the power to
overrule the federal government during
certain conflicts and a lot of the power
that we assume the federal government
has might have been reserved for States
because of the Tenth Amendment however
the Trump administration can counter and
say that it's merely protecting federal
property and that the CBP is legally
permitted to help Federal Protective
Service protect federal buildings and
that might effectively give the
president a big personal army of more
than 60,000 employees and officers and
while in the abstract this might not be
the worst thing of course the federal
government needs law enforcement
officers to enforce federal laws
unfortunately we're seeing a pattern
here as we've learned over the past
three months the Trump administration
will meet vandalism and property damage
with an overwhelming show of
paramilitary force against American
citizens and in DC effectively bill Barr
Attorney General was in charge but here
it's the Acting Director of Department
of Homeland Security Chad Wolfe who has
not been confirmed by the Senate
I don't need invitations by the state
state mayors or state governors to do
our job we're going to do that whether
they like us there or not and his acting
deputy Ken Cuccinelli who's also the
Acting Director of Citizenship and
Immigration Services CIS has also not
been confirmed by the Senate and a
federal court ruled that Cuccinelli was
not lawfully appointed to his position
and therefore he lacked authority to
issue several directives pertaining to
immigration but he's still on the job
and in fact he has two jobs
moreover Mark Morgan the Acting Director
of CBP also has not been confirmed by
the Senate and neither has Matthew
albuns the acting head of ice or his
acting deputy Derek Benner and of course
the pattern of a mouse wanting a cookie
and a glass of milk continues lawfare
reports that an internal DHS memo
authorizes intelligence collection of
Americans in order to protect statutes
and memorials the Department of Homeland
Security says that their intelligence
and analysis office is quote collecting
and reporting on various activities in
the context of elevated threats
targeting monuments memorials and
statues and it gives legal guidance
concerning the quote expanded
intelligence activities necessary to
mitigate the significant threat to
Homeland Security posed by such
activities again we're talking about
statues here the intelligence collection
is authorized to prevent quote damage
sufficient to impede the purpose or
function of monuments if you know how to
impede the purpose or function of a
monument or statue please tell me in the
comments and of course the pattern
continues again DHS is apparently making
plans to send over 150 agents to Chicago
for unknown reasons under unknown
Authority this is obviously a very
worrying trend but thankfully there are
brave souls out there willing to legally
observe these protests and tell us what
is happening thanks to them we have
video of what happened to Christopher
David in Portland who stood in front of
the federal law enforcement officers and
asked them about the oath that they took
to the Constitution while they pummeled
him and broke two bones in his hand he
just stood there like a friggin tree and
if you go out in the protest like
Christopher David and the person that
recorded what happened to him and want
to put together the best videos you can
you should take penny lane Skillshare
class filmmaking from home turn found
footage into a compelling video ahhh
2020 where even the segways are
incredibly dark Penny's class will help
you take your footage and turn it into a
compelling video like how the federal
government is do surfing States and
turning cities into occupied
paramilitary zones penny developed a
unique approach to storytelling that
transforms existing content from
historical archives to YouTube videos
into innovative or irreverent films
Skillshare as you know is an online
learning community that has tens of
thousands of classes on everything like
music design technology and business now
a yearly membership is less than $10 per
month but the first 1,000 legal eagles
will get two free months of Skillshare
when you click on the link below plus
clicking on that link it really helps
out this channel the free premium
membership gives you unlimited access to
must know topic so you can improve your
skills and learn new things all free for
two months just click on the link below
it's get two free months of Skillshare
so do you agree with my analysis do you
think that there should be limits on
federal law enforcement being used in
the States
leave your objections in the comments
and check out my other real law reviews
over here where I talk about all the
legal issues in the day and all the
crazy things that are happening in our
cities so click on this link and I'll
see you in court